hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to let's play creepy zone
creepy zone I think that's the name of
it um
once again not much information on the
thing not even the pictures in the game
were very descriptive or on the website
so click the link in the description
below if you want to play it it's always
gonna be there whenever I can get it cut
out okay this is made on the FPS creator
engine so it's pretty much similar to
flashlights I don't have a flashlight
yet so it's very dark it's really what
is that that a chair hi
someone's walking around that sound is
actually quite good that that a doorway
or window I'm gonna go near that yeah
that is a chair what are you doing there
but on well I think you're doing it's
always unsettling when a chair is just
kind of standing there facing a random
direction I don't know why it shouldn't
be that weird but it is okay so nothing
so far okay it's just automatically oh
boy ah
Oh smile dog that smile dog that's more
smile dogs go ahead my dog ha ha oh you
died ok the hell's going on here that
seems strange is these window panes
light panels are awfully detailed hi hey
freaky all right I guess we're going
through the maze here this is the only
thing that there was an image of on the
website so hi you die okay this is
strange
not sure if it's all that scary but
strange I'm more confused than anything
all right
okay then how do I use this I don't have
a use button I'm trying to left-click F
oh there we go F oh hi
what the hell are you like some bunny
man stop turning that on and off what is
you oh I picked up a weapon oh god this
is not a weapon this is a flashlight
what do what the hell was that what was
that I don't know okay racks of beef a
giant mannequin which I do not like what
was that it was like some weird bunny
man funny man okay bunny lady do not
like you stupid mannequins
all right I'm actually noticing some
similar
what's that there I think that was there
before I don't like this I'm noticing
some similar elements to other FPS
creator games the FPS creator thing is
actually quite interesting like I
haven't I haven't bothered to get it
myself because it costs not a lot of
money but some money that I'm not
willing to spend unless I'm gonna
actually create something but you all
can try it out it's easy to find and
apparently it's pretty easy to use so
you guys want to give it a try oh this
is probably where I'm gonna lose a
monster or something I don't know I
can't jump so okay that's an escape
route that's a dead end
what's AHA I knew it I knew it
he's traveling bats going wait are you
even chasing me not I don't care I'm
running away anyway and it's really
quiet
but IRA light on let's go see what the
bunny man wants what do you want bunny
man you gone you're gone ain't you okay
I didn't need to do anything gonna open
for me
where's a key where was there a key
there wasn't even any place to go
must have any key on like the table in
this hallway here it's really quiet
why is it so good ah okay thank you I'm
going now I will leave ah - Christ
Shadow Man
what the hell holy balls
Jesus get away oh my god follow me down
this hallway this is what this was for
Jesus gonna pop honour here I Bobby her
haha oh god damn that was surprising
please open open open open open over the
room would wait what what we're going on
I don't know I don't know no I do not
know I do not like Oh what uh-oh
that's a pretty good model I've never
seen that in FBS creator with this ah
what happened where am I are there so
many many good stop crying where's Holly
mannequins I'm a gir stop crying toughen
suck it up please weird intestines are
just growing out of everywhere okay is
it cut out of that what was that oh that
was the most despised I'm running here
so mommy I don't know what that was
what the hell was that huh I don't know
why yeah well I don't know I'm not even
joking that was like the creepiest thing
I've ever seen oh yeah inches
was it a head I couldn't tell what it
was okay
all right I'm done here so Jesus what
was that thing should he use that and
set a smile dog Jesus anyway so thank
you all so much for watching click the
annotation for more videos that I've
done and as always I will see you in the
next video bye
Oh
I love
Oh
love